nicole kidman maybe an Academy and Emmy
Award winner but you know what guys she
is also our bay of the day and what an
honor that is truly she's been busy
working on big little lies to Aquaman
and destroyer and now she's on the cover
of Allure magazine
Oh Nicole she's a goddess is she really
a real human she is the best at
everything okay get it yes hey but get
this as acclaimed as she is she tells
the magazine she doesn't consider
herself to be famous can you believe she
told the mag inside I don't see myself
as a celebrity I'm not a celebrity I'm
not a movie star I feel like I'm an
actor
Beyonce is a celebrity is she coming
from a be right there Lauren was a low
shade I don't think it's she I think she
just means well interesting I go right I
think Nicole probably meant except
interviewed her a bunch of times she's
the sweetest is that Beyonce has this
celebrity status like people clamor and
dragon girl for her I will say as much
as I love Nicole Kidman respect her I
don't like like the people scream for
Beyonce to grant certain you know and
she's most likely to be able to like
step foot out in public or maybe go to a
public where I think people would come
up to her but I don't know if there's
certainly no I definitely yeah so Nicole
checking at our check out if you want to
the full cover story at allure dot-com
again next movie though did you see this
trailer you guys here's the thing Nicole
Kidman beautiful goddess looks amazing
but this is her in the new movie
destroyer okay she plays an undercover
cop in this movie and she's our Bay of
the day no matter how she looks for her
talents for the crafts for her amazing
motherhood but Kelty night talked to
Nicole about this transformation at the
Toronto International Film Festival here
they are all right I'd like for you to
get into character
because obviously you're not home
shipment like you you don't really look
like that because that's my job as an
after and that's what I wanted to and to
be nice buzz so you know if there's room
for you the way I want people to see the
film because for me it's about the truth
of this woman medicine and it's you know
there's a reason yeah and so I don't
really see it as transformation I just
see it as being authentic and true to
the particular journey of this woman
anyway she's been in her past the way in
which it's played out physically and
emotionally our control room just told
us they're blinded by Nicole's highly
Ohio as we are and you know what so many
highlights look at that transition for
Nicole she's done the transformation
thing before though I remember cold
mountain I think for a little prosthetic
nose the hours oh the hours she won an
Oscar for the late that's destroyer top
of the lake how to talk to girls I mean
she really truly is a chameleon and like
she says she's an actor's actor so she's
like it's not about the transformation
I'm just becoming this person absolutely
why she's so good at what she does oh
yeah oh look at this is actually from
how to talk to girls
oh man looking like the Broadway version
of cats and we will be with Nicole at um
coverage and I think it's an AFI event
it would be destroyer tonight so ET
we'll have more from Nicole off the red
carpet tonight will bring that to you
tomorrow
[Music]
[Applause]